you will date again you'll find love
again well I just don't want to right
now it just seems like can you imagine
the guy can you imagine let's say you
know who knows when let's say six months
from now I don't know what you're gonna
do you're gonna meet somebody maybe
you'll go on one of these dating apps I
don't know what you're doing I
definitely won't do that but yeah I'm
not again I love them I just am not and
I'm just that scares me but I do like
the
you know the the bit I mean I can't
I I can't ha it's not fair like you know
what I'm saying like people know me you
know what I'm saying someone is going to
have to ask you out in other words if
I'm a guy and I'm single oh no I have
people out I do ask someone out yeah so
it's possible once you get over the
trauma of what you've just been through
and you start to come over the trauma I
just really enjoy uh me right now how
long will it be before I see you dating
Pete Davidson this is what I think is
gonna happen that call it a premonition
here's the thing Pete is cute and he's
funny that's right that's what all the
women say they're saying he's cute and
he's funny so that's why I mean I I
don't picture us dating no but I just
mean like but I but people always is the
headline here you're not interested in
Pete Davidson
did he not call Pete Davidson you are
wonderful but no I'm not looking now
here's another name I'm going to throw
at you you know who's single now
I I wouldn't Tom Brady the football
player athlete wow you and Tom Brady I I
here's the thing I have a lot of
confidence I'm a very confident woman I
don't think I'd like to follow Gisele
Bundchen
I I am really confident
I don't know that I'm following that
like think about that when you're making
out with him right like uh tell me your
celebrity crush maybe I can make this
happen give me an idea my celebrity
crushes aren't like um real people
they're like the characters they play
so I don't have like a celebrity crush
like in a real per I don't know the per
I I love their characters like castle
like Nathan Fillion he plays Castle like
I I've run into Nathan he is so lovely
and he's so cool we've um I went on his
show the rookie and they came out on my
show I love him but I don't know him but
I love Castle so like that's I have like
crushes on like fake people you want an
older guy Kelly Schwarzenegger think
about it I don't work out enough that
would be an intimidating relationship
I mean it all
foreign